e
I'd like to go ahead with the meeting
today which we have scheduled for the uh
oversight education oversight for the
looking at the Improvement and
assessment here in
education and uh we this is the 1 two 34
or whatever rendition of our looking at
the 306 administrative rules
and so what I'd like to do today is we
have two sections the back half and the
front half I'd like to pass out to
everybody here some research which I've
done regarding the back half and the
issue um where do the academic standards
belong I had the opportunity to work
with research across the
street and and also had a lengthy
discussion with the commission of
Education uh at the trustee meeting
in Keen this past week on Friday so I'm
I pass a sheet out so we can look at and
where
what has been located or
understood goes that way excuse me Mr
chair yeah I I thought somebody from the
Department was going to come Julie Shay
is supposed to be here okay I spoke with
the commissioner about that and he's
trying to make those recomend you know
to get that to occur um he had other
plans himself for today uh seeing he's
come here numerous times and explained
the 306s
and and he discussed the areas which we
had con I had concern we had concern and
I have some feedback on that but I'd
like to First Look at the back half here
and what we have in statutory law right
now and why we have it in statutory
law Jen I do have some sheets here for
gathering you're
welcome if you're looking at at that
sheet right now we had this discussion
where do academic standards belong so we
don't have to get into this long
discussion and debate again today
just looking at it in and starting in
1998 there was a bill passed and signed
in law it was HB
1075 this is back
before we had the current definitions of
everything that we have right now this
was a bill that created RSA 193 and at
that time there was no
193e they created RSA 193 E1 2 and 3 193
appeared on two pages in the statory
books following this this bill so we've
significantly added to it um as of 1998
the term academic standards did not
exist in
statute HB 1075 contained the three
sections of an adequate
education and contain two paragraphs and
I put them both down below there one
reads New
Hampshire in New Hampshire that public
education and secondary education shall
provide all students with the
opportunity to acquire the Knowledge and
Skills necessary to prepare them for
successful participation in social
economic science scientific
technological and political systems of a
free government now in the years to come
that's sort of what we have today but
then they had an education that is
consistent with a curriculum and student
proficiency standards specified in State
School approval rules and New Hampshire
curriculum
Frameworks that's how it was said back
then the student proficiency standards
are are term which have since been
changed to education standards and then
to academic standards by the legislature
in subsequent
years respecting New Hampshire's long
traditional Community involvement it is
the purpose of this chapter the new 193
to ensure that appropriate means are
established to provide an adequate
education through an integral system of
shared responsibility between between
the state and local government we have
that in law in this system and this is
what they put in there in this system
the state establishes through school
approval and student proficiency
standards and curriculum guides the
framework for the delivery of
educational services at the local level
so through a school approval and student
proficiency standards again echoing the
the those standards now there's nine
steps I think I yeah nine nine steps
what I put in here it's trying to get to
from where we were back then and if you
go into the office here and look at our
the 1998 statutory law you'll see those
two paragraphs I just
read going down this number one the Bold
underlying sentences identify the
student proficiency standards
were what is called today academic
standards number two that an adequate
education is consistent with the
curriculum and student proficiency
standards specified in in State School
approval rules and New Hampshire
curriculum
Frameworks so proficiency students are
in according to this the New Hampshire
curriculum standards number three
statute reflected that student
proficiency standards are specified in
approval rules and the curriculum
Frameworks four student proficiency
standards now called academic standards
are in those curriculum Frameworks in
2016 all references to curriculum
Frameworks were removed from Statute in
2016 student proficiency standards were
replaced with new terminology called
academic standards academic standards
were defin defined as meaning what a
student should know and be to do at each
grade
level going further from 26 216 with the
removal of Frameworks over the next
years confusion existed as to where
academic standards could be found and
confusion is a word that I think we is
really reflective of what we've been
trying to do up here at times trying to
find the location where these things are
supposed to be by 2024 the term academic
standards has further changed academic
standards means what a student should
know and be able to do in a course or at
each grade level that was added in
slightly different from
2016 number eight in 2024 the
legislature and recognition that by
implementing statutory reference to
curriculum Frameworks the leure had
legislature had also deleted reference
to where academic standards SL student
proficient standards could be located
that back referencing back to
2016 the legislator passed 1107 we just
recently did placing curriculum
Frameworks back in the statute in RSA
e2a the following definitions now in law
curriculum framework means an organized
plan of study that serves as a guide and
reference to what New Hampshire students
should know and be able to do in
learning in a learning area and
identifies the academic St standards
aligned with each learning area pursuant
to RSA 1932a 1A in summary academic
standards are meant to be in and
identified within the curriculum
Frameworks academic standards for
learning content areas identified in
that
RSA U belong in the Frameworks not
administrative rules the administrative
rules and Frameworks are linked by
reference so that's how you know I've
gone through and tried to do that
research along with research people
across the street and looking at the
statutes that we've had from 1998 going
forward um so that's where we stand and
my my my feeling right now is that we
know where the academic standards are
supposed to be they're supposed to be
located in the Frameworks and referenc
to those
Frameworks there's a link so in the
future when we modify these rules we are
also impacting academic
standards so I'll open up to discussion
here yes represent cellan well thank you
um for uh doing that research with OS I
I think it's helpful and provides uh
context um for this um and I think
context was also one of the words used
by the commissioner um was it last week
in talking about the the Frameworks and
en Compass the standards um and maybe in
a couple of the Frameworks the the title
was uh guide rather than Frameworks but
um I think that the uh intent is there
and I think um including uh the
Frameworks by
reference um and possibly in the
appendix um is
uh the proper um
alignment of things uh so I am U fine
with uh what has been
proposed represent Luna um sure um thank
you very much Mr chair I'm I'm certainly
not fine with what's been proposed
because we haven't even begin uh to uh
review the um the the list of um of uh
you know concerns that uh that we had
that that were presented and discussed
during the the last meeting on October
uh 21st so so I think um I think we're
jumping the gun um to say that that
we're ready to to go forward with this
without first um having those concerns
addressed I'm I'm frankly I'm I'm
shocked that there's nobody from the
Department uh here to uh to help us um
uh where we can inquire with the
department and get some answers to uh to
these concerns um I think it continues
to show their callous disregard to the
legislative process which is required in
statute and uh and frankly is required
by JL car as well and uh and given the
the that JL car uh will certainly
consider uh the public interest as being
being uh important when there's nobody
from the Department to answer questions
from Representatives who represent the
public I think this is a clear violation
of um of a process that uh that avoided
the um uh that that contradicts to the
to the public interest so um so I hope
what we're going to do this morning is
um is see some people from the
department and there's nobody here right
now and um and that we can get some
answers to um to the questions that uh
that came out of the um the uh came out
of our last meeting and uh and you know
not not only did we have questions that
were related to the definitions but
questions that were related to the rules
uh themselves and um and also I think
questions related to the impact that um
that requiring compliance with um with
with Frameworks um which are now in the
um uh you know it's now required in the
uh in the back half of the rules when uh
when Frameworks are defined even as most
recently as House Bill 1107 which was
signed in the law and went into effect
on September 10th that uh discusses the
framework say guide and reference so so
I you know I think there's there's
there's a lot we need to do to
understand what um what the impact would
be on um on on our schools and and I
think you know at the at the 30,000 foot
level Mr
chair and the governor even said this in
his um State of the State address in
February that that New Hampshire's
Public Schools public school students
perform among the best in the country
and um and we've talked about this
before I know it doesn't happen
everywhere but on average um New
Hampshire Public School students perform
the best in the country what's going to
be the impact on um on on that on those
student outcomes given these new rules
and uh I think we need to take a very
careful and thoughtful approach as we
move forward here uh the fact that
there's nobody here from the Department
uh to answer questions in the public
appalling okay i' I'd like to just you
know roll back to
where why I read through this report
that I put together trying to go through
the history of it yes our our students
in this state compared the rest of the
country do very very well in terms of
academic achievement and performance and
growth where I want to really get
clarified here and to me it's a
legislative responsibility to clarify
this not the Department's responsibility
to clarify where are these academic
standards found when I went back and
looked at the 2001 ccum Frameworks for
the
Arts and I saw within that clear
reference clear
identification what standards are it was
there standard one standard two standard
three when I looked at other aspects of
these Frameworks I also saw that in the
health there are some Frameworks which
we
have that need cleanup I will concur
100% on that there are Frameworks which
were adopted just recently like or not
recently but in recent years here like
the the the mathematics standards those
are referenced very well too to clear
standards science a little different but
it also has reference to those
overarching performance standards that
we want students to achieve in those
science areas so the if there's anything
that comes out in terms of a policy
recommendation I would say that it's up
to the legislature to say these
curriculum Frameworks need to be
reviewed by the department be it through
a task force through department
administration at least every 10 years
to update and to ensure that they're
reflective of what we have in statute we
do have in statute and I'm thoroughly
believing that now based upon how we
defined performance student proficiency
standards changed it to education
standards prior to 2000 you know when we
were doing No Child Left Behind which
kind of messed us up too and then we've
gone to the academic standards I think
we have to decide where these things are
located yes there's other things we need
to discuss today but we need to get past
this hurdle that the academic standards
are to be located in the curriculum
Frameworks they can be reference from
rule to
those but we need to be able to say to
our Educators out in the field here's
where you go to find the academic
standards yeah and Mr chair and I'm I'm
in agreement with that I think that that
makes a lot of sense because when the
commissioner was here uh a few weeks ago
he referred to the AC he referred to the
Frameworks as the academic standards as
opposed to containing the academic
standards well just to clarify that when
I met with him on Friday down in Kean he
said they are housed in the curriculum
Frameworks they are the curriculum
Frameworks are not they contain the
standards as well as other guidelines in
terms of how to integrate those
Frameworks into curriculum and and thank
you that's a very good clarification
from what from what what I heard yeah uh
during that um during the time when the
commissioner was um was here but but
just going back to the Arts and I know
we talk about the Arts framework because
it's the very first rule in the back
half rules and I think it's you know we
we discuss it as exemplary you know for
all of the other ones as well but the
Arts framework and and this was also
discussed um uh during that uh during
that meeting a few weeks ago the Arts
framework has not been updated since
2001 and um and so what are we losing by
by now requiring not only that uh that
uh that public schools incorporate the
academic standards from that 2001
framework but now also the um the
curriculum and competencies aligned with
that 2001 framework that would seem to
me to be taking a step back um you know
using a framework that was constructed
you know um uh 23 years ago uh uh uh so
you know what are we losing with that
what are the costs associated with uh
with implementing uh curriculum and um
curriculum that's aligned to a 23y old
framework uh uh and doing that in every
Public School across the state do we do
okay yeah and I guess do we even have a
a fiscal note uh impact on what these
rules would cost to imploy go to Katie
first representative pen no yes thank
you Mr chairman um just have a question
I want to clarify the purpose of our
committee and we are to review and make
recommendations is that correct that's
correct
so part of our recommendations could be
that the curriculum um Frameworks be
updated I mean I agree 23 years old 23
years is a long time but maybe next in
the process is the
re-evaluation and rewriting of the
curriculum Frameworks to come up to
Modern stand but that's part of our
recommendation that's not in the purview
of our committee here to start reviewing
the curriculum framework that's correct
we're getting into the business policy
and and that's our responsibility yes
but we're looking at these which we're
looking at statutory reference that the
Frameworks contain and house the
academic standards now just because
academic standards were written 20 30
years ago doesn't mean they're outdated
necessarily and so in in looking at some
of the standards we've looked at them
when we talked about health and we were
looking for mental health which are also
in the academic curriculum or the
curriculum
Frameworks and I believe they spoke to
the issues which we needed to have a
reference point when we're looking at
legislation last year dealing with
mental health and how it's done in the
schools so I I think we're we're leaping
if we and I agree with you
representative peternell that maybe it's
there was an effort back when this first
bill HP
1075 there were numerous amendments that
came in from various directions one of
those amendments was also looking at
should there be a time frame in which
curriculum Frameworks are reviewed and
and looked at that didn't go forward at
that time so I I concur with what you
just said represent P represent luno
yeah so um you we we do have that in
statute now that curriculum framework
should be um uh reviewed and updated uh
on on every 10year cycle that was that
was part of uh of House Bill 1107 that
that um that we passed this year but uh
but given that that the the the back
half of the rules the the rules that
pertain to academic standards are
replacing what's in rule right now with
a requirement for public schools to um
to uh uh to have their compasses and
curriculums shall shall align with the
curriculum framework for the Arts in
this case April 2001 edition uh since it
hasn't been updated in 23 years aren't
we sort of put in the cart before the
horse should we update the Frameworks
first before requiring compliance to
Frameworks that are over 20 years old
represent cordelli thank you I I would
just um observe that uh I don't think
nothing in here is changing the
standards the standards have been the
standards um nothing is changing the
standards that we have in place um
should they be reviewed uh probably so
um and that is um in statute now but I I
don't think that anything in here that
we're supposed to review is actually
changing the standards that are already
in place oh sure Mr chair yes represent
pel I I I kind of get the sense that
what representative luno is suggesting
is sort of the cart driving the horse so
if we look at
statute um defining um giving allowance
for rules and then that leads down to
the iic standards and the curriculum
Frameworks and then the curriculum at
the bottom if you will a pyramid we're
we're setting up the process to move in
the appropriate manner we can't um
create the curriculum Frameworks unless
we have the rules to direct the
curriculum Frameworks is that am I not
is there something there that I'm not
understanding correctly in that process
yeah so so uh yeah thank you Mr chair
and and thank you representative pel um
my understanding is that the curriculum
Frameworks are defined in statute um and
and that definition was was um clarified
in House Bill 1107 that we passed this
year and so so the um the what what a
curriculum framework
is is defined in um in statute what what
we're considering here isn't statutory
it's rules and and to change the rules
to that that did not require did not
mandate public schools to to implement
curriculum uh the curriculum
Frameworks
um where now the proposed rules would be
that schools have to comply with the
with the curriculum Frameworks seems to
be out of order that that that going
going back to your very good analogy
that curriculum Frameworks are the
foundation of the um of the of the
pyramid here that that those should be
developed
first followed by the rule you know and
approval of those Frameworks which I
think is is um is subject to uh to the
state board and to this committee and
then rules that rely on those uh
Frameworks that would be mod ified next
and U uh as opposed to starting at the
top of the pyramid and uh and I I mean I
just think we're we're doing this in the
wrong
order um represent pno thank you I think
representative luno and I have a
disagreement about the purpose of the
pyramid and I understand his reference
to building the pyramid from the bottom
up because you certainly wouldn't start
from the top but that's not how our
legislative process works we start at
the top and everything funnels down to
the
bottom but but this and I I'm I'm sorry
this is turning into debate what we're
talking about here is rules not not
statute so so this
is this committee has a legis has a
responsibility to recommend to review
and recommend uh rules and and
and I'm not talking about
legislative our legislative
responsibilities when it comes to
statutes um talking about our this
committee's responsibility to review and
recommend rule changes and uh and
frankly the Frameworks because that's
now in here too so so it
would appear to me um and you know that
that that we would start with the framew
Works make sure that the Frameworks are
are um you know make sense that they're
updated that they're that that they uh
are are going to um you know do well for
our for our students and then update the
rules accordingly to refer to those
Frameworks as opposed to updating the
rules first to refer to outdated
Frameworks that haven't been looked at
in in in some cases in 20 plus years
ref s Celli yeah I I think that uh to
say that uh they haven't been looked at
in 20 some odd years um there was a
process that the uh uh department and
the board state board went through um
Consulting with many people um
Educators um and citizens alike and um
part of that my understanding is they
did look at um some people at least in
the department reviewed um those
Frameworks and those standards and U in
some cases probably they did but also I
think we heard that some of the uh the
art uh uh standards that were discussed
um seemed uh quite uh quite good um at
this point even though they're 20 years
old but um I I don't
see um we're in these rules making a
reference to Frameworks uh
um uh do we change the rules every time
in every 10 years that we change the
Frameworks it's just a reference to the
Frameworks the Frameworks are going to
change um as time
requires um so I I don't think that we
need to change uh the rules other than
the reference to the framework so I I
think that uh the process that we are
going through is the one in terms of
updating the the rules to make sure that
they are referencing the Frameworks and
therefore the standards but I I think
that um certainly 10 years ago we had
quite a bit of discussion about math and
English uh standards when Common Core
was adopted by the then State Board of
Education and uh some of those dis
discussions continue today so um at
least for those standards there has been
ongoing review um since that they were
proposed and adopted by the state
board and at that time the math
standards came before the Improvement
assessment uh group and they were
approved by this committee at that time
yes thanks thanks very much to
representative cordell's um um comments
I you know I appreciate the fact that
that he feels that the that the Arts
Frameworks are up to-date and good and
relevant stuff like that but there's
nobody here from the Department to
actually ask them what they did to
review the Frameworks prior to
incorporating all of the Frameworks into
the um into the minimum standards for
for school approval so we just don't
know there's nobody here from the
Department to testif testify on that and
then and then
further and I think the department could
have organized this too are some content
experts to actually you know attest to
what representative cordelli suggested
uh which is the relevance of those 2001
Frameworks there's nobody here that can
um that can testify to the um to the the
significance of how those Frameworks
relate to what students should know and
at what grade level uh by course uh uh
we we there's nobody from the Department
here represent L we're we're looking at
though the academic standards student
proficiency standards call it what you
may they are located in the curriculum
Frameworks and when I'm looking at even
Part B within 30627 which is Arts
education it says each school's Arts
education program shall have
competencies and curriculum aligned to
two k through 12 curriculum Frameworks
for the Arts April 2001 edition as
reference in a appendix
2 now whether the the Frameworks have
been updated or not or reviewed or not
that's not a question before this
committee at this point in time the
question is does this change in
rule accurately reference the the or
direct the educator the field to where
they can find that content you're
talking about the content now is within
those standards and Frameworks it's not
in
Rule and so you know I I I I don't
really have a problem with the way it's
written Mr chair yes thank you um I in
reference to your um Point number six on
the second page one of the um topics
that I did find confusing until the
introduction of 110 of um House Bill 11
7 was what how were um school districts
educating their students without the
curriculum Frameworks over the last what
was their guideline what were they doing
so I think your point number six is
clarified with the proposed ed3 306
rules and the addition of House Bill
1107 because there when I look at it I'm
confused what were schools using as
their guideline for their curriculum
statute sir further discussion on this
issue I don't think just just finally so
Frameworks are in statute now and it
says that they are to be used as a guide
and reference in statute and then the
proposed rule says the program sh um
shall have competencies in curriculum
shall so it's a mandate so the statute
uh says that the curriculum Frameworks
are a guide and reference and the
proposed rule says that the curriculum
Frameworks are a mandate that's those
are two different things so wearing our
our our um you know lawmaker hats uh the
rules are in conflict with the law the
law says their references the rules
suggest the rules sorry the proposed
rules say that they're um their mandates
but at the end of the day the um the you
know the statute says that school
districts shall use the Frameworks as a
guide and a reference not as a mandate
so so I there it's it's there they're
not um you know they're not just
floating off in
space but again that statutory language
which we passed you the first part is
correct but it says
should and it goes on should know and be
able to
do and those Frameworks are aligned and
contained the academic standards so the
the statute that we have in place I
think very accurately says you shall do
this and he says should okay yeah we can
always say change should from Sha to
shall um but we you know I'm looking
back to when it was initially put
forward and back in
1998 and it says School approval and
student proficiency standards and
curriculum guidelines the framework for
delivery of Education Services at the
means uh where yeah and it says right at
the first paragraph there in 1998 shall
provide all students with the
opportunity to acquire the Knowledge and
Skills necess necessary to provide them
for successful
participation
um I I I think it's pretty clear to me
as to what they're doing here the the
rules are not the
standards and I think we've got to
eliminate that confusion and saying
you'll find those standards in their
Frameworks now Frameworks need work then
that the department needs to get on the
horses and do it but that's not or we
through policy would direct them to do
it uh legislation I don't think that's
necessary that's their responsibility
that's the state board's
responsibility and I think I believe the
State Board is moving in that direction
what we probably need to do is support
them with the curriculum staff to do it
so Mr chair given given what you just
said why would we adopt rules or
recommend adopting rules that refer to
curriculum Frameworks that need
work and that should be upd
why why would we do that why wouldn't we
start with the Frameworks and and get
them settled to where where you know and
this a State Board responsibility we
review and recommend get the get the
framework settled to where um where they
should be school districts are already
um it's already in statute that they use
them as a guide and a
reference um uh uh to what New Hampshire
students should know I'm reading from
the law and be able to in a learning
area and identifies the academic
standards align with that um um uh
learning area why wouldn't we why
wouldn't
we recommend the State Board start there
and then um uh and then once those are
settled uh put those Frameworks into U
reference those Frameworks through rules
because the rules are the minimum
standards I think that's what the state
board's trying to do I think they're
trying to file what hb17 s said and what
previous legislation has said and now
they're saying yes if you want to find
these standards they are located over
here in the curriculum Frameworks
they're they're just doing it backwards
you according to our current
statute there's a requirement to follow
the current curriculum
Frameworks so I'm not sure what
difference it makes whether they update
the curriculum Frameworks before we
adopt these rules or after because
either way they're now required to
follow those curriculum Frameworks
so why would we undo all of the work
that the department and the board of
education has done on these rules and
set them back how many more years these
rules will be will have to be reopt as
written without any new
recommendations am I am I missing
something in that
process represent cor I I don't think
you are missing anything um and I just
go back to the point that the
Frameworks contain the AC St academic
standards and the academic standards
have not changed they have been and
continue to be the standards to which
curriculum is to be aligned at the local
level
period And if those academic standards
are to be changed that's a
responsibility of the State Board of
Education
correct so Mr chair I'm missing
something here
um you said the academics if the
academic standards are to be changed
that's the responsibility of the State
Board of Education but you you missed
something over that only after review
and recommendation by this committee so
we have a role in in this um whether
that and that includes a role in in
reviewing and recommending the minimum
academic the academic standards we now
have a role in reviewing and
recommending the um the minimum
standards for school approval and the
Frameworks those are the two things that
came out of house bill 11
1107 so so to say that the state board
has unilateral Authority
to or to suggest that the state board
has unilateral authority to modify to
change the academic standards is
absolutely contrary to um no no but it's
contrary to uh
e2a um um Roman 4C the State Board shall
not amend any existing academic
standards and Sh shall not approve any
new academic standards without the prior
review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee this
committee and that's that's how
important the legislature uh felt back
uh back back when this um uh provision
was um was adopted that that that the
State Board doesn't act alone in this um
in this area
uh the the State Board is not
unilaterally adopting academic standards
we're looking at a process a procedure
in which that would occur now when they
want to look at the Arts education again
and change current standards then we
have a responsibility to review and
recommend those standards back to the
state board but that's not what they're
doing right now they're saying we're in
we're locating those according to the
way we've written this 306 is that
they're going to be located they are
located over in the Frameworks they're
not Chang in the academic
standards and that's where we have the
opportunity as a legislature to review
and recommend when they do make those
changes but there's no changes occurring
here oh sure yes there are because what
they're and again just looking at at um
at what was formerly rule 30631 ARS
education now
30627 um the what's in the existing rule
is being being deleted and the proposed
rule is replacing that with the with a
requ with a mandated compliance to a
framework and the framework has
different language than what's in the um
the current rule it's absolutely
different there was no requirement to uh
to uh to to there was no mandate to have
um uh uh curriculum and
competencies compliant with the the
curriculum Frameworks it said in statute
that they're a guide and a reference and
um and so that is that's changing uh so
and and and the words are changing too
what was what was in the the what's in
the existing rule is being replaced by a
u u you know uh uh a curriculum
framework that was adopted back in
2001 represent cell yeah uh going back
to the 1107 language there are two
pieces to it first is that the
Frameworks are a guide and a reference
to what they should students should know
not shall but should know that's a whole
different discussion what they shall
know uh but the second part is the
Frameworks identify the academic
standards and that's all we are trying
to or the department is trying to do and
us via our review is is to put into
rules I think what has been um a de
facto rule uh if not um more than that
but that curriculum is to be aligned to
the standards we we've talked about that
in relation to um the standards for
years um uh I know with common core
standards there's been great debate and
we said that uh um
uh districts had to align to the state
standards or higher standards if they
wanted to develop something higher than
the state minimum standard academic
standards um I think Manchester did do
that didn't they revise the um was the
math common core standards and upgrade
them to what they thought was higher
level so I I think that nothing has
changed in that regard we've always been
um trying to align curriculum to
academic standards and this is just
aligning the rules to point to those
Frameworks further discussion on this
yeah I mean this is it is the cart
before the horse it is doing it
backwards modifying these rules um to uh
to sit on top of a shaky Foundation is
forward I would disagree with you're
saying it's on a shaky Foundation
obviously over the last years our
students in this state have done very
well academically based upon the
standards we have in place the academic
standards or student Prof proficiency
standards as they were initially
called um that's not Shaky Ground uh
what we're doing is eliminating
confusion as to where you find these
academic standards the academic
standards are properly located as was
decided back in
1998 and messed by us roundwood in the
legislature numerous times and changed
the names of this you know it's been
student proficiency standards back when
No Child Left Behind was in in play and
we're looking at that and revising to go
into the current Elementary secondary
Education Act it went to education
standards then academic
standards um all basically just the same
thing and and so I think this is really
clarifying the process where you will
find they are housed in the curriculum
Frameworks we're not changing it that is
another issue if that's going to occur
and that's up to the State Board to make
that decision the Department of
Education working with the state board
and the State Board working with schools
in the state if they want to come
forward with a recommendation or new set
of art standards or other subject area
learning area sub as standards do so and
we they will come before us for our
review and recommendation but that's a
step down the road right now we're
making sure the procedure is in place Mr
chair represent pel yes thank you very
much at the end of the day um I find it
offensive that representative luno
speaks to a shaky Foundation because I
find that comment to be undermining all
of our local Educators because
regardless of the decisions that you
make here and now they're the ones in
the classrooms they're the ones teaching
their students and saying that the
foundation is shaky is undermining the
trust that the parents and the public
have in their Educators and any quality
educator knows exactly what their
students should be learning at each and
every grade level and in each and every
course that they are taking and I find
it offensive that we're undermining the
shaky Foundation of our quality
educational opportunities for students
in the state of New Hampshire and I find
a high value in our local Educators and
they should be applauded for the work
that they do every single day for the
students in our
state and I I would just chirp in on
that I don't think we have a shaky
Foundation we allow flexibility for our
loal schools and that I think was
reflected back in the 1998 law there
yeah school districts then have
flexibility in implementing diverse
instructional approaches Mr chair I'd
like to just um respond to um to that
comment um again I I think what's
offensive and has undermined public
confidence is the fact that the
commissioner of Education nor any um me
hey I'm speaking point of order you I
find discouraging comments about the
right now from the Department to answer
any questions that uh that this
committee may have and I believe we have
a number of technical questions uh on
this subject and uh and that uh that
that process has really undermined
public confidence in this matter well I
I I disagree 100% with you on that uh
represent luno uh the I met with the
commissioner we spent over an hour hour
and a half looking at and we have
another sheet which I want to go through
and look at on the front side that he's
unable to be here today yes I thought
Julie Shay would be here however she's
not here today irregardless he has been
here he has explained over and over I
think there's just
a a concern that's being brought on
behalf of those individuals that you're
hearing from ripson luno that the
process that is being done here that's
being established that Echoes statutory
law that we've had in place for years we
need to have this really put down in
place so we eliminate that confusion
that may be out there in terms of where
do I find the academic standards it's
not our task today to deal with those
academic
standards those academic standards are
approved by the state
board and after we review and recommend
uh but we're not dealing with it we're
just looking at process procedure right
now so I I would we don't have a flex a
shaky Foundation the commissioner has
been working with us on
this and has attended meetings and he
said I can't be there I will you and I
sat down with him and we discussed this
and and quite frankly I think what you
see in front of you that I wrote down is
exactly where I stand right now um that
we have a a a a process going forward
where person can locate these academic
standards whether you believe the
academic standards up to Snuff that's
your individual perspective that's fine
change that's that's all I have on that
on this part is there anything more on
the back
yes you want to do a five minute break
break when
I met with Frank we had some areas that
we had discussed within the front half
that
work
e
we're going to go ahead and jump from
the back half to the front
half and address some of those issues
which we had at the last meeting the
issues which I had a again as I said a
lengthy discussion with the commissioner
on
Friday when we looked at 306.000
2 in in the front half and we've gone
over this many
times um there were certain definitions
within that and item M within it the
definition of educator I understand
going correct me if I'm wrong that
there's now been a change where the
reference to
RSA 21-n col
8-d parentheses C has been added in
into uh the definition of
educator and that definition states that
it means a teacher or certified PA
professional then if you look down later
into the rules It also says that a
classroom teacher has to be certified in
the area that they're teaching other
words they take their their elementary
teacher they're qualified to teach
elementary Ed it's not just going to be
somebody that has a degree
in physical education or the sciences
and taking the practices there they have
to take be qualified to teach an
elementary Ed so um if in fact the
reference to Ed um or excuse me RSA 21n
is in that definition I understand it is
then I'm good with that definition for
educator further discussion on
that yes I I believe that that was uh as
you said a discussion at the earlier
meeting and that the um uh commissioner
had said that they would uh add that and
U if that's the case I am fine with it
as
well is that the general consensus of
the committee
no no I I thought last week we had a
problem with defin definition of
educator because it included
instructional special par Educators
educational interpreter trans
literator School nurses and any other
individuals
credentialed and are we not talking
about that same one right
now we're talking about
M yes no we're we're it's been I think
what they've done is reference
specifically to the RSA that I've talked
about Mr chair yes yeah um thanks do do
we have um final language on that to
review and recommend or or or is this a
you know you just said I think what
they've done is uh do do we have final
language of of what they're
changing um I'd have to look in the web
because I'm I'm U you know I'm very um
cautious about making any sort of
provisional um acceptance of a of a
change without actually seeing the final
language Mr chair yes another question
in regards to the purpose of this
committee we're just reviewing and
making recommendations correct not
approving these that's right we're not
we're just reviewing and recommending
F going on down
then um to the next issue which we had
discussed and when the commissioner was
here when it came to educator he also
referenced another section I I've got to
find that right here to support the
definition of
there was the part that's spoke to
having to have be qualified for the area
that they were
packet is me
189 that one talking about and talking
about a a rule other rule see of another
rule
supports you know that this definition
of Ed it just further explains the
educator must have the
credential for that particular learning
instructed maybe what I'll do is do a
quick
call come back to that yeah let's let's
just let's keep going on we'll get some
a response uh to you for that ref and
luno um the next one down which we had I
believe was 306.000
020 committee discussed def from
Extended
I you know when we talk about Extended
Learning I think the the the rule
does
[Music]
um I I'll just open up there any further
discussions on that that
component you're you're talking about on
on the 602 um 02
I no oh sorry oh we get extending
running opportunities on page four oh
yeah yes o o is the sorry the proposed
rule I is the existing rule yeah
um and you know we talked about adding
back the examples that were um that's
right that were in I and U we also
talked about how um how in the in the
definition of Extended Learning
opportunities in O that it talks about a
personalized learning process which
actually deviates from from current law
uh in terms of the definition of of
elos
and we also
discussed in in paragraph R under
instructional time uh keeping the
definition of instructional time that's
offered in
um oh Sor sorry I've moved on
sorry I thought it was part of the same
thing you know if I were to make a
recommendation as I'd recommend that the
that rule that we have there under
o have reference in appendix one that's
where all our references
are I i' reference that back to where we
have the
definition or mentioned Extended
Learning opportunities as mentioned as
in 193 col
one uh I I'd make a reference directly
to
it uh that way it would
include those
areas that that those components of
Extended Learning are such as those
those
areas Mr chair I would agree with that
um because if I recall correctly when um
the commissioner was here we brought
that we discussed that and we were going
to reference statue RSA 193 colon one 1
H1 2 and 3 and that includes everything
that was would have been
formerly
in I of the old rules or the current
rules I should say yeah so in in in in
that statute it references 193 colon
1 1 H then parentheses
one these plans may include but are not
limited to such components or
combinations or of components of
Extended Learning opportunities
as and it goes en lists those areas so I
think what we can do there is just you
know recommend that that reference
rules
and yes or did uh put the reference
directly into o or I I just reference
statute because that way you're not
changing right but yes reference that
yeah so how would that how would that
read Mr chair how would o
read
um well I I I have to go back and get
here yeah it means a personalized
learning process allows for achievement
accomplishes through means of outside of
the
classroom and pursuant to and I just put
RSA or or just even not even having to
change it there I would then reference
back
rule you know
30602 parentheses o and I put in the
pendex one the the reference that we
we're referring to the statutory
reference so so just to be clear when
when when a rule
is is um is is backed up by a statuto
reference
that that statutory reference doesn't
become part of the rule the rule is
saying that that it's backed up by by
that but in this case you want to you
want to reference the statuto the
statute in O uh because of the um the
the list of of you know including but
not limited to and the the various um
I think it accomplishes it either way uh
by doing it this way you're you're not
change anything you're just making a
rule yeah I don't I don't think that's
as as complete does you know having it
um so why change it
yeah we we you can leave it just as is
yeah
yeah okay yeah I not make any reference
well leave it leave it as is the in the
current rules in the current rules yeah
no I meant leave it as it is leave it as
it is in the current rules if we're
going to reference it
it Mr chair yes I believe when we had
the discussion when the commissioner was
here we were trying to make this um more
streamlined so in every situation where
instead of reiterating the statute we
were just going to reference the statute
so that or we would recommending that
the statute be referenced um just to
rules I don't think making things
streamlined makes it easier for people
to understand and find if they have to
go looking in an appendix to find out
what it really
says I they have it right in front of me
then have to go looking for it right but
if the statute changes then you also
have to go back and change the rules
also yes so it's easier just to have the
point so on we're going to have to we
can go down here and approve things as
we go one way or the other um is
there because at the end of this I'd
like to make a you know have a show of
hands in terms recommending this thing
as with X number changes or no changes
or what to the as approved by the state
car
um H where where statute
or or reverting back to the way it
was I I would not like like to see it
reverting back to the way it was and I
think in terms of a recommendation um it
would be uh very general recommendation
and that the uh um definition of
ELO's um uh reference statutory language
in uh
yeah in some way manner or form whether
it's directly in o or in the appendix um
I think just the fact that we're making
a ref a recommendation for reference to
statute is sufficient
okay okay is that a motion
yes second okay Senator Ward seconds
that um any further
discussion although just show a hands
those people in supporting that those
opposed
okay it's 4 to2 so we'll move forward
with that reference to RSA 193 one
Etc in the
appendix um going on to the next that we
had was 306.000 2 R I believe that was
time I fine with uh the
rule so Mr chair yeah last week um um we
discussed and I think it was generally
um uh the the
the last week we discussed uh keeping
the existing uh definition of
instructional time from uh current
paragraph
K because there is a
difference between during a time which
instruction is offered versus a period
of time which pupil are actively working
outcomes but we also in that
conversation we're talking
about instructional time
varies from elementary to Middle to high
school um recess for example is
instructional time cor correct whereas
it wouldn't be at the middle school
right right and and I think we found
that in in statue
um if if my my memory serves me on that
but but um but there's there's a clear
definition a clear difference in meaning
when when you're talking about a period
of time where instruction is offered and
a period of time which pupils are
actively working towards achieving
educational outcomes those are two
different things one of them is is is
students making progress is student
centered the other one is not student
centered so so uh you know that this
isn't this isn't just you know word
smithing um this
this this is a very significant change
um and one that U that impacts not just
uh paragraph R and some you know rule
30602 but uh translates into every rule
um and everything that uh that schools
discussion okay let's let's take some
action on that uh who wants to put
something forward here oh okay yeah I'll
I'll move that we um we uh uh replace um
paragraph r with the language from
existing rule paragraph
K and that language being no
instructional time means the period of
time during which pupils are actively
working toward achieving educational
objectives under the supervision of an
educator or other staff member correct
thank
you is there a second I will okay we
have a motion to uh change the rule back
to the current rule as was just
opposed okay that was T
to four
so is there a subsequent motion yes
represent cordelli uh yeah my motion is
to
um
uh support the recommendation of the uh
state board on um our instructional time
sir second second represent uh Pell
seconds
discussion all those in
opposed those opposed to Y
okay going on to the next one which we
had
discussed and I believe this one right
on
did you find it no I'm looking for it
too
I don't think there is
one is that a typo
errow no it's I think it's on page seven
what did that Dr
us dual and concurrent enrollment in
no it's 3064 B
no I know there's obviously a type
enrollment you see that under I think
I think I think the
B is wrong I think it just goes down to
21 I think it's supposed to be a
parentheses a parentheses 21 and it's on
page 14 at least that's what I have
circled and then I've D how students can
opportunities could be yeah yeah there's
yeah I I think that as it's done right
there is
fine I had
added discussion language and we had and
we had decided at the last one to leave
it as is and I have a no in my
notes um I had dual and concurrent
enrollment college courses include and
then I had Early College High School
Early College online and Early College
on college campus
enrollment
and
I I don't see any need for any changes
there
I I I hav no just leave it the way it is
M so anybody wants to change
that skip it
this was the issue of kindergarten
12 yeah can we go back to page 15 page
15 yes culture and climate I I don't
know if I'm being P it's say the school
board the school policies adopted by the
local school board shall reflect and it
changes to to the school board shall
is
that you're in the middle page 15 yeah
36.6 06 culture and climate
yeah it it's changing it from the ones
that they do telling them that they
shall
address does so is is your is your
question uh whether there's a statutory
underpinning requiring a Schoolboard
can we tell school boards that they must
adopt
them that they
must well current rules if you look at
3065 um the local school board shall
direct
so this is
see well there's a number of statutory
references to 306.000
6 and they're in the back of
uh there's 190 189 1- C 189 colon 15
18974 19423 F 194 C4 2 Roman 2 C through
appendix so I think I I think
representative Cornell's question is
that is there a statutory reference
four
one of the referenced
areas in the back in the appendant is
189 col 15 and I'm just looking at that
right now and it's titled
regulations the school board May un L
otherwise provided by Statute or state
board
regulations prescribe regulations for
attendance upon and for the management
classification and discipline of the of
the
schools um and such regulations when
recorded in the official records of the
school board shall be binding upon
pupils and
teachers so that that's one
board the directive from the state down
to
locals Mr chair yeah could could we ask
um um uh Schoolboard Association to to
just sort of
really comment on
mandated is that all
right well I mean just the point just
the point you're welcome come forward if
you want Barrett but I 18974 School
Board public comment period School Board
shall provide the opportunity for a
public to comment there is places
throughout
statute um um where we're directing how
school board's going to
function and right right right there are
there are there are but there's also
mandated policy welcome Barrett thank
you chairman lad good morning members of
the committee Barett Christina from the
New Hampshire school boards Association
most of the policy requirements um at
least in rules are in 306.000 4 where it
lists out a number I think there are
probably 25 or 26 policies that are
required in that provision of of the
current minimum standards everything
from attendance and absenteeism to
bullying to homework to um how credit is
earned to hazing um a whole host of sort
of what I'll call partly behavioral
things bullying hazing um uh uh uh uh
attendance and absenteeism and then a
whole host of policies that are required
relative to what I'll call academics
curriculum homework how credit is earned
learned um uh uh Advanced coursework for
for a kid may be in eighth grade taking
uh an advanced math class so that that
would count for credit when they get
into high school I think I mean I
haven't counted recently there are
probably if we were to look through the
minimum standards alone the current
version of the minimum standards there
are probably between 30 and 40 policy
requirements within within that as well
too and then we have a number of as I'm
sure this body knows we have a number of
policies uh School Board policies that
are required in statute some of those
are also included in rules some of them
are not um for example we know that the
bullying statute requires school boards
to have a policy that is incorporated by
reference in the minimum standards um
we've had some some bills the last
couple of years about um I believe
concussions and and injuries relative to
to student athletes that require school
boards to adopt a policy I don't believe
those Have Made It by reference into any
of the Department of Education rules the
public comment policy that was enacted
two years ago I believe that is not part
of the minimum standards or any of the
Department of Education
rules I'm trying to think of what other
ones may have been um I don't think I
don't think the Manifest Ed um
provisions and RSA 1933 I could be
mistaken about that I don't think those
are inquired are included by reference
in any of the any of the Department of
Education rules I could be wrong about
that those might be the minimum
standards but so we've got a
if you will of both regulations
Department of Education regulations and
statutes to say nothing of a federal law
that requires school boards have any
number of policies on any number of
topics some of those have made it into
the minimum standards or other
department of education roles others
have
not and I'm happy to answer any
questions very helpful thank you you
have a question represent your red okay
so or several on the next page broad
statements that in terms of culture and
climate that school boards adopt
policies for um is there any objection
okay let's march
on um yeah you're talking about an
objection of 30606 yeah um well that's
the one that represent Cornell just
brought up right right right yeah yeah I
would I would I would suggest uh
reverting back to the original uh the
current
just going right rather than having the
policy
mandate any policies adopted by the
board shall reflect and and you've got
the four yeah four points on
that I I would say leave it leave
it go back to the existing back to the
original you want to make a motion yeah
I'll I'll um I'll move that um that that
30606 uh reverse back to the um the
existing rule
language I'll second it okay there's
motion the floor to revert back to the
current rule for 306.000
6 all those in
favor all those
opposed okay it's two to
defeated I all moved in we support the
uh proposed
3066 sir
second okay we have a motion to support
the ed360 6 rule being presented by the
state board all those in favor I those
42 uh
30607 was an area where we had
discussion
of course there are rules for school
too in Ru making in administrative
rules especially when it comes to
that right right and I think M Mr chair
I I I think if I recall the the
conversation we had the discussion we
had last week surrounding this is that
Ed 320 which the proposed rule
uh has as its only reference only has to
do with application for um for
um um Renovations or new new you know
new building design it doesn't it
doesn't it does not refer to existing um
uh buildings it's
only for um for new proposed uh changes
to buildings so you know given the fact
that that most of our school buildings
are existing structures and um and will
continue to be that way until such time
uh a um uh a school district approves of
Renovations or something like that in
conjunction with Ed 320 uh that school
boards still have to operate school
facilities uh According to some sort of
rule so so uh the existing 30607 7 talks
about what those facilities how those
facilities shall be operated
including um clean healthy and safe
learning environments lighting and
compliance with codes exhaust and
outdoor ventilation property temperature
humidity uh all these things that would
not apply to existing buildings if we
320 represent Celli yes but in in the
current rules
30607 um it's referring to statute so
all those things are currently in
statute so I don't need I don't see the
rules Mr chair yes
question it's referencing uh Ed 320 do
320 yeah we can you they're right there
on the
um and they they they do talk about
Etc square footage all that for
addresses the the three the 320s are
see would say that that pretty much
covers what we need to
consider yeah I think the reference of
320 really
discussion so I I would I would support
uh just leaving the 306.97
board okay so we have a motion on the
table all those in favor of leaving just
as is as presented by the state board
one is 30608
MD the conversation we had is this
section directed towards
media library media centers or Does it
include all instruction curriculum
resources necessary to support learning
uh when I met with
the commissioner last week it's in
intended to reference all resources not
just
libraries and I think that's what he
so Mr chair yeah how does the um how
does the existing rule then not also
apply to um all instructional resources
that being the first question the
secondly do we then lose the um the
requirements uh as appropriate um for a
um for uh a library collection to be
cataloged and classified according to
practices
Association or or or under the new Under
the proposed rules could
they have the collection organized any
want well did you look at all the
references that this is referencing to
and
306.000 1891 it goes there's a whole ly
of
referencing the American Library
rules so if the Library Association as
some organizations do
change you
know what you know policies they have
are we automatically having to change
too I would say
yes
uh I've been recently approached by a
group wanting us to automatically
approve school psychologist based upon a
national National Association but what
happens if that National Association
changes do we have to also change our
certification requirements um there are
a lot of issues when we reference
specific organizations or
associations should we not should we do
it or should we not do it and that's one
of the major changes I see in
this represent cordelli uh yes I I know
when I look up um my local public
library
online um to look for a book you know I
can search by Title by keyword by author
Etc I'm not looking
um based on a catalog of um food uh Das
uh stake uh Dash something or other um
that might have been in the old card
catalog I'm looking based on uh modern
search uh
technology um and I think the same holds
true in school
libraries Mr chair yes yeah I I I would
just put forth that I think that's a
very uninformed opinion
and that uh that you know we we don't
have any obviously uh expert testimony
here from anybody that's a uh
credentialed um School librarian or
somebody with a master's degree in
library science that's trained in this
area but to imply that uh that our
public libraries and our school
libraries are still operating in uh in
the 1950s uh of card cataloges is I
think just endemic of somebody that
probably hasn't walked into a library in
a in a long time but uh but certainly um
certainly you know
Library organization and
cataloging um standards have uh have
evolved and continue to evolve and um
and compliance with those sorts of
standards for um for collections and
school libraries I I think probably have
done our students um well in terms of
their ability to to search primary
references both in the school library
and in public libraries across the
country um and um and to uh to take it
out and and let it
be sort of random um it does a diservice
to um to our kids and I i' I'd be very
cautious about about um removing that
existing language thank
you yeah I wasn't trying to imply that
any public library any school library is
um back in the
1950s um they're not they're in uh uh
current they're using current technology
uh to help people find
materials and I think that um the need
for uh the current a to be carried
forward in the new rules is uh
dating back to the
50s I'd like to add on that if you look
at the last item within this section
item
D the and it's speaking to the school
board responsibilities implements a plan
approved by the District administration
for ongoing development organization
acquisition maintenance replacement and
updating of curriculum and learning
resources necessary to support the needs
of students so I think this is fut F
istic looking at you know they're
looking at you we have to be current
with our resources that we're using
um and without getting down into the
weeds and mandating that you do a per
use a particular
system
um
so there again I I I think this
is the
uh and and if we see a need to change
policy then we can recommend policy
changes through legislation but I think
in terms of rules right here I think
they are supportive of the current
statutes and there's no reason to say to
object to uh what is being proposed by
board so is there a motion so move okay
representative excuse me
Senator board made a motion to approve I
I believe you're approved or to
recommend the State Board recommendation
on D yes yes on on on D on the whole
thing on the whole section yes the was
it the one well I just read that one
section to support what they're doing on
the
entire area which we're referencing
there in
306.000 N D is is one we had discussed
yes is there a second to recommending
support for what's being uh presented by
the State Board second okay we have a
motion made by Senator Ward and second
by representative cordelli to approve or
to support I guess to is it support or
approved because we don't do we review
and recommend yeah recommend support
support of the State Board
30608 all those in favor I I okay for
all those post
two that takes us through the items
which we
so like to go ahead then and
uh if there's any further discussion or
recommendation represent cordelli
yes I would uh recommend
support for the uh proposed Ed
306 uh
rules with uh any
recommendations um made by uh this uh
oversight
committee Mr chair is there is there a
second second okay so there's a motion
on the floor made by representa cordelli
and second by Senator
Ward yeah thank you very much Mr chair I
believe we also talked last week about
proposed rule 306 uh rule 14 which is
also in the front
side yeah we did and so are we um are we
going to have some conversation about
that yeah we should have some
do you want to I'll motion and
I'll okay so we are back to no motion on
the table uh
30614 deals with
uh student teacher ratios so let's move
to
that and so um so Mr chair my my
understanding would be
since we met last week that
the that the proposed definition of new
def that there's a proposed change to
educator that is referenced in this
proposed rule is that correct that's
that's our understanding and that's
would be our recommendation that it be
pursuant to that that RSA we put at the
very beginning 21 and right and and and
I had back when we were discussing that
I had requested that we be able to look
at final language um on that before
um before moving forward with it because
um because I think the the I think the
final language is is going to be very
important and um and and I think last
week's
discussion or maybe it was
uh two weeks ago's discussion when the
commissioner was
here talked about how there would be a
some sort of additional restriction of
being able or not restriction but
additional um
um uh what's the word I'm looking for
here um
um I I guess limitation on on on the Ed
Educators that would be used in the
calculation of the ratio that they would
have to be certified or sorry
credentialed in the um academic area
being taught whether that was Elementary
or you know math at in middle school or
something like that and um and that we'd
only and that the department would only
use uh would only consider Educators
that that met that content area um
condition and but doesn't say that in
the rule well to respond to that it does
but not in that rule it goes back to
A3 where the hiring and training of
Educators license under ed500 to
facilitate learning in their credential
content
area um
so and we we're talking educator and
earlier we're saying Educators have to
be certified
according to
21n colon 8 I believe it was and and and
I asked the same question again to the
commissioner on Friday and he referenced
back to this section in
30612 where it's requiring that they be
in their content areas and that's where
they're certified in so a classroom
teacher in a grade school is going to be
Elementary certified
by the
department so that's how I see that
connection okay so what's what what was
that what was the rule reference on that
uh back to well we were we're talking
about 30614 educator ratios right right
but but then that references back to Ed
it and see there's under that there's a
and there's item two and item three so
current rule
15 new rule is 12 current rule is 15
professional staff and staff
qualifications I'm looking at the new
24 so so so uh the proposed rule 30612
references the proposed Rule
30614 and it does so under on page 24 on
the side by side in um in A4 the number
of Educators sufficient to satisfy the
so these are ratios not class size so so
school
right or in a or or in in a in a Grade
range you're you're talking about class
size too when you're like in
kindergarten well it's talking about
ratios to it's not talking about it's
titled student ratios yes student
educator ratio
right but then it's also covered by that
0.12 rule where the
Area 25 students or fewer per
educator so I I would I would agree that
in 141 where it talks about
kindergarten 25 students or fewer per
educator that it's talking about
Educators
and we don't have the final language of
that of that definition so I'm only I
don't recall where that landed the
educator it was something it it it
rolled in that the
21n
8 D DC right teacher or certified Pro
par professional something like that as
right or or I'd have to go back and look
means a teacher or certified PA of
professional
young but see a certified par
professional to the best of my
understanding would not be the teacher
of a grade one
classroom so so let's let's um let's
pick Middle School just for or or high
school for example where where you've
got
educator is is would that would the
librarian
be used in the calculation of student
teacher ratio
yes okay so high school for n you know
and would it would it be done
by for the entire School 9 through 12
and it would include everybody to finded
in an educator that's certified to be op
be practicing professionally in that
High School including the building
principal including the the um school
counselor including the librarian
including the um the the teachers and
all subject matters uh uh divided into
the number students in grades 9 through
12 would How would how would that ratio
be
calculated educator um pertains to
yeah so be your music teacher your PE
teacher took the practice and certified
high
school so then so then at at the high
school where we I'm on page 28 on the
side by side proposed rules in paragraph
three Middle School and High School 30
students or fewer per educator uh is
that per per classroom
or is it per content area so if there
um uh 90 students and
three teachers or or I I don't know how
to calculate it
um 90 students taking
Civics
and one teacher
qualified certified to teach Civics is
that a 90 to one or is it a 30 to one if
sections or if they're teaching five
one teachers can teach outside their
content
area what is it 50% no but I'm just just
going with what you're talking about Mr
chair the the the certified to teach in
a Content area because I think that's
the that's the the the condition that
that you have said is going to be
applied to this Rule and I I think we
heard the commissioner um talk about
that condition I used that when I'm
speaking to the elementary teacher but
when in a high school you may have
somebody has a wonderful background and
something but they're certified in
mathematics but they're teaching a
language
class that's
acceptable if the majority of their
times in their content area map no no I
I get that I get that too um I'm just
wondering how the calculation going to
be done because it doesn't talk about
these conditions of being certified in
an area um number of students taking
classes in that area and maybe you've
got the math teacher teaching a couple
SE
civics and and now it's okay to include
in the calculation an educator who's not
credentialed in that instructional
area and and none of this is spelled out
in rules well if you go back to
83612 it talks about the number of
educator Educators sufficient to satisfy
the student educated ratios in
um I think this allows
that you know we're not really I don't
see how we're really changing this from
what we currently have no no but but I
but Mr chair because it's a rule
shouldn't it be clear on how how these
ratios are Cal calculated do we are we
really just leaving it up to the
building principal or the superintendent
or the school board to calculate it any
way they want um and and I'm I'm not so
I I mean I think you're right when
you're when when we talk about
kindergarten and Elementary kindergarten
two and then Elementary grades 3 to 5 3
to 5 I don't I don't I don't know if if
those are if they're content area
certification at those grade levels or
if you're just talking Elementary
certification I I don't know the answer
to that but at the high school level
Middle School and High School level I
think you're talking content area
certifications and and now you've got
other professionals that are that are
also included in the definition of
educator and are they going to be used
in as part of this calculation is that
condition are there going to be any
conditions that apply to um uh to this
rule cuz it's just not it's just not
spelled out
and and I think this is and it's an area
that I think has had a lot of concern
from the
public um looking at page 28 side bys
side um uh
three uh middle school and Senior High
Schools 30 students or fewer per
educator is the same in the current as
well as the proposed
um and we know via was it
30612 um that we're dealing with an
educator um in that content area so I
don't see how um we're going to mix in a
um a music educator in a figuring out
the ratio for a math class so so just to
respond to that Mr chair I think that's
I think that's an easy response on that
and that in calculating class size you
know exactly who the educators are in
that in that class and uh whether it's a
uh let's go back to the Civics um um
class example whether it's a a teacher
that's certified to teach in civics or
somebody that's certified to teach math
that's picking up one section of civics
and and obviously and the principal you
know feels feels good about that that
person's ability to uh to teach that
section that that that in that class you
in that class because it's a class-size
calculation not a ratio calculation in
that class uh you've got one teacher and
up to 30 students that would be the um
that would be the hard you know limit
based on the current current Rule and um
and now in the the ratio rule uh we're
not talking about about a class
anymore they're talking about multiple
sections of a Content area maybe maybe
you're talking the entire middle school
maybe and and as as you said Mr chair
the the um the the
librarian and I guess the principle and
the school counselor could be considered
in that
calculation did you said the librarian
would be yeah it's it we're talking
about a situation go down to the grade
schools again where you have a classroom
teacher for grade three or two but you
also have coming in throughout that week
one fifth of that time is probably going
to be made up of a music teacher
librarian uh art physical education so
the prep periods right negotiated
agreement so but you're still going to
have to have a ratio in that regular
classroom with taking the extras out but
you're also going to have to have those
extras hired on board so your your
ratios you you're going to be in for the
classroom you're going to have to make
sure that that ratio is 25 to1 in grade
two but you're going to require
additional staff to get all your content
subjects taught so you're going to add
more certified teachers into that
mix so so M Mr chair I I I I agree with
with that as an as an approach to to to
limit class size but that's not what the
rule says the rule the proposed rule
does not talk about classroom doesn't
use the word classroom anywhere well it
does in in the in the kindergarten grade
3 through 5 it says class size of 25
class size of 20 no no that's a that's
aspirational shall strive to achieve a
class size of 20 students yeah but the
rule is 25 students are fewer per
educator and and I great I I do agree
with you that kindergarten through
grades two and and I guess to the extent
grades three to five where where
educators are certified in Elementary or
early childhood you know education
that's that's a little bit easier to um
to um come up with the uh the total in
the denominator but in high school and
and that that there's there's no such
definition Middle School and High School
30 students or fewer per educator and so
so that's a ratio and so so you know
hooping in Middle High School has has I
don't know um um 450 kids in it and and
you've got um you've
got you know so many teachers and that's
the ratio because that's what it says in
the
rule represent Cordell but is there any
change from the current the current does
not
say class size as had been um and is in
the uh uh lower grades no no the the the
current rule specifically is class size
not for middle school and high school it
absolutely is because it's it begins
a and it has paragraphs 1 two and three
under paragraph a so a is class size for
instructional purposes in each School
shall be and gu kindergarten through 2
25 grades 3 through 5 30 and middle
school and high school
size well then in the current rule how
do you justify then that shall be versus
in um one and two for those lower grades
strive to achieve the class size so is
it so is it shall be or strive to
achieve so you've got that in the
current rules so kindergarten through
grade two 25 um or fewer per 25 students
or few are per educator so that's that's
the class siiz
ceiling um and provided that each School
sh
shall you know strive to achieve a class
size of 20 or fewer per educator and I
think that's where where Miss Wilson um
discussed with us uh last week that uh
that from a budgeting purpose that's a
good place to start because you don't
know who's going to be moving in moving
out what your final you know enrollment
is going to be and that provides it
provides a little bit of breathing room
between um you if you've got you know
four sections of um of Le let's say you
know third grade then you'd have if you
were budgeting for 20 per classroom um
four sections you could have 20 kids
move in and you'd be at 25 per classroom
you'd be at that ceiling but you you
started with a good budget uh budget
amount and I think that's why that
language likely exists and I think
that's what what Miss Wilson um
explained to us yesterday or last week
um but don't you need that same
flexibility at middle school and high
school also yeah and you've well you've
got it in in at grades three through
five and then at the high school um you
don't have a you don't have an
aspirational in in either but you have
some
exceptions well I'm just saying for
larger classes you know um and that's
for your study halls no study halls band
and chorus you've got that and and and
those those are um those are true is is
well in in the current rule it's it's by
class size in in in the proposed rule
so um but in the current
a class size and each School shall be
and you flip over to three Middle School
and High middle and Senior High School
be in the current law as the way I read
it and so with the proposed rule you're
adding that
flexibility so that um it based on
students moving in and out um you're
providing that flexibility that you're
uh achieving or you're striving for in
the lower
grades I'm I'm I'm failing to to see the
point because it under the current rule
for high school class size for
instructional purpose in each School
shall be I'm just going to go right to
the high school middle and Senior High
School 30 students or fewer per educator
that's class size that's what it says 30
students are fewer no there's no strive
to achieve that class
size um you could you could you could
certainly I mean strive to achieve is
sort of a I mean that's that's not a
requirement that's an aspirational thing
and I and I and I'm sure um having been
on you know Schoolboard for a dozen
years that that um when when when doing
schedules and looking at you your April
15 um renewal dates and all of that type
of stuff that you've you've got a
general idea what sort of program you're
going to be offering and what sort of
class size you're going to be um you're
going to be uh you know experiencing and
um
and you know and and you know it's not
saying that it's not saying in the
current rules that class sizes have to
be 30 students per educator saying 30 or
30 students are fewer per educator so
you could certainly strive for 25 or
drive for 20 um whatever your um you
know school board and and voters uh you
know accept during that whole budget
time represent
pel I think that the rule change in 3061
14a gives a lot of latitude to the
school board to determine the classroom
sizes
I
mean establish student educator ratios
that promote student learning for each
learning opportunity and learning based
upon school safety policies content
instructional method the characteristics
of Learners and the following these are
just number
guidelines um but gives them a lot of
ability to move based on students moving
in moving out different learning styles
I mean these rules have to last for 10
years unless
there's another change in statute
sizes you know there's differing demands
too in these high schools are you going
to have the same number of kids in your
general math class as you are in an AP
class I don't know but many smaller
districts the AP class is going to have
a few students and it's
hard to staff these based upon our
funding formula but um
it's I think we need as representative
peros that flexibility for the school
board to make these decisions and and to
prioritize and I think that's what the
new statutory language is trying to
do so so thank thank you for for that Mr
chair um I when when you talk about
flexibility you're I I hope we're
talking about flexibility to uh to to um
provide the right um level of
educational services to uh to students
and um and you know the I I think with
ratios I think with class size it's very
clear very clear and I think the level
of flexibility is certainly there in the
existing rule um um I have no problem
moving over the um you know some of the
U the language from new paragraph a that
uh promotes learning and and and you
know based on safety policies content
structure methods I think that's all
good good stuff and and probably should
be in the uh the existing rule but um I
think the level of flexibility that's
being afforded here um afforded school
boards and superintendents and building
principles here is to is to look at
class or look at sort of sorry student
um uh student teacher ratios across uh
an entire School building across an
entire grade range an entire um um
subject um matter and um and and be able
to see widely varying uh class sizes as
opposed to class sizes with a with um
with a hard ceiling that um
um as we have in in the existing uh
rules and I think there there was
probably I I don't have a breakdown of
the of the comments the the public
comments that came back on the usuals
but this is clearly a lightning rod area
where um where I think families across
the state um uh don't want to see um um
certain classes balloon in terms of uh
uh uh class size just because the
student teacher ratio across the whole
this is a huge huge issue and it even
gets into funding side of the coin and
where we talk about the original input
formula based on student teacher
ratios um
it's yeah it comes down to the local
board making those CH decisions and to
the town legislature whether they're
going to support the dollars to to
enable you to do some of the things
you're speaking to but I don't think
that the rules here are curtailing that
from happening I think there're B
basically I think
they're the same as basically what we
have right now no they're they're
removing the guard rails that are in
doing
yeah okay is there any further
is there a recommendation or a
motion yes represent cordelli uh yes
recommendation to support the uh
proposed um
rule with the understanding that that
first definition of educator changes to
reflect the
statute right we we already made that
recommendation of yeah but to to ensure
that that's
occurring um okay okay I think that's
it's all tying together here okay okay
is there a second on that second okay
the motion made by represent cordelli
30614 rule recommend recommendation of
the State Board contingent upon the
definition of educator also
incorporating the RSA reference to the
educator any further
discussion sure yes yeah just we we also
haven't seen the um um final language
for the defition definition of educator
so so this is this is all based on
provisional um whatever well it's based
on this this this action right here in
front of would be contingent
upon the def the educator referencing
that statute
yeah yes representative perinel I just
again want to bring us back to the
purpose is that we're not approving
these we're making we're reviewing and
making recommendations thank
you okay all those in favor I I four and
those opposed
so we had now we had nothing else that
we had discussed earlier from previous
sessions relative to the front side like
to have a
motion and the motion would uh basically
reference that first change
that I believe they've already made but
we would our rec recommendation would be
contention upon
that that the definition of educator
reflect the
RSA somebody want to make a motion here
representative cordelli so
move to approve the back half and the
front half both yes the the entire 306
proposed rules with the um
recommendation also of the the educator
reference to existing statute yep and is
there a second m m Mr chair second was
made by represent P yeah just being
really clear on the motion the motion is
not to approve as representative pet
said it's to recommend and and being
very specific it's recommending to the
State Board which is which is our um
statutory yeah so so could could could
the motion be that uh the motion be to
recommend to the state board that uh
that the rules um as presented with the
one change to um the definition of
educator to the state board and jalkar
nope our our just to the State Board
okay for just making it to the is that
good with a second to the State
Board okay all those in favor of the
motion I and those opposed two oppose so
it's 4 to2 to recommend to the State
Board uh that we support the
rules the front and the
back pending the decision
to amend the section dealing with
educator to
reflect the RSA definition of
educator okay so that's where we
are that's where we end that's where we
end that's where we end
um certainly that okay we'll just leave
there yeah any further
discussion not seeing we are
yeah yeah get my optometrist get my
glasses yeah I was I was bushwacking
behind the house and the classes fell
off in this stuff and it was on the side
of a cliff I couldn't find them so I'm
these
e